y llegó el momento de presentar a
nuestra segunda invitada del día ella es
vanessa burggraf la directora general de
nuestras cadenas de france 24 vanessa
bonjour bienvenida aquí a nuestros
estudios en bogotá
buenos dias vanessa cuál es la
diferencia que aporta france24 en
español en américa latina en un panorama
no de cadenas internacionales en español
que ya es bastante concurrido vanessa
sí hay una gran competencia es verdad
pero constant cat tiene especificidades
en este país y hoy soy latinoamericano y
es que nosotros ofrecemos muchas
explicaciones y análisis de la noticia
no nos limitamos a presentar
informaciones serias
nos tomamos el tiempo de descodificar y
analizar la actualidad y están los
valores propios de nuestra cadena
propios de francia son los valores de la
laicidad la igualdad entre hombres y
mujeres insistimos mucho también en la
diversidad de hecho podemos ver esta
diversidad
la cadena puesto que todos los
periodistas de france blanca de
hispanoparlantes vienen de todas las
regiones del continente latinoamericano
y peruanos venezuela anos colombianos
argentinos la diversidad es algo muy
importante para nosotros
son estos valores franceses que son tan
queridos para nosotros es la cultura del
debate nos gustas en el debate en torno
a la actualidad por eso este habrá una
emisión que se volverá cotidiana en la
cadena el debate que hasta ahora
presentaba una sola vez por semana horas
todos los días la diversidad entonces en
fans bad cat mismo se ve en las cuatro
cadenas la cadena en árabe francés
inglés y español
estas cuatro cadenas se alimentan una
gente unas a otras por ejemplo
tienes en la cadena en español vamos a
hablar de los problemas de áfrica
utilizando los reportajes hechos
sináptica en francés y en árabe y al
contrario
se adaptarán los programas de unas a
otras
hay una transversalidad entre estas
diferentes cadenas y esa es la fuerza de
vanessa hablabas de un tema muy
importante que es la diversidad que
tanto nos enriquece en nuestra reacción
sobre todo acá en bogotá y por supuesto
en nuestro edificio en parís cuáles son
los dominios a las áreas de cobertura
más importantes para nuestra cadena para
france24
los temas que nos interesan en nuestra
cadena en primer lugar la cultura
francesa porque la la cultura francesa
hace soñar al mundo ya sea la
gastronomía ya sea la moda la cultura en
general se habla se habla mucho de los
artistas franceses en nuestra cadena y
también en el canal de ustedes hoy en el
mundo la cultura francesa entonces es
muy importante para nosotros también las
mujeres como como les decía antes nos
interesa mucho la igualdad entre hombres
y mujeres por eso esa emisión tan
importante que tienen en su calle que se
llama ellas hoy en las cuatro cadenas en
los cuatro idiomas entonces las mujeres
son muy importantes para nosotros y como
ya lo dije la diversidad en postbank
hablamos mucho de áfrica también y para
eso lo hacemos en la cadena en español
cuál es el balance de estos años de
operación para la cadena en español en
términos de audiencia en la web las
redes sociales
la audiencia aumenta día a día gracias a
ustedes gracias al trabajo que ustedes
hacen en esta cadena en español algunas
cifras que muestran esta realidad
hicimos estudios en méxico colombia y
argentina y en estos tres países tenemos
más de tres millones de espectadores por
semana es un muy buen comienzo y
seguiremos así y también en el aspecto
digital porque una especificidad de
nuestra cadena
en español es que ilusiona muchísimo y
en el mundo digital nos y los resultados
también lo dicen también tenemos tres
millones de visitas al mes
nuestros aspectos digitales
91 millones de visualizaciones de vídeos
en youtube desde comienzos del años
entonces muchas felicitaciones a ustedes
muchas gracias a todos los espectadores
latinoamérica y podes vanessa las
gracias también es a ti por querer y
nosotros por estar aquí visitando nos en
este día especial cuando pasamos a 24
horas de programación en español francis
4 creciendo cada día más y pues todo lo
que hablamos la diversidad y la
importancia de la mujer en nuestra
cadena vanessa me así gracias por estar
aquí conocemos